yeah so you're you have a gambling issue
I got a real gambling problem would you
say uh well first of all what is the
go-to if you go to the casino oh I gotta
go to baccarat bro that's an old person
what James Bond how do you I don't even
know how to play that yeah yeah how does
that how do you play I don't lie bro uh
that's some senior citizenships man you
be playing next to people with like
their oxygen tank and [ __ ] nah I'll be
next to the Asians the Asians love that
[ __ ] Asians love it bro yeah like but I
wanna I play it like an Asian though
like what's that mean I'm great you're
really good I'm great hey Asians love to
gamble bro you go to that high limit
room there's a bunch of Asians in that
[ __ ] where I'm at baby yeah you
you wanna find me come find me in the
hot lemon room like I'm I'm I'm near
[ __ ] some cigarettes like I won't lie
all right I never I never even I never
told nobody this like uh you've seen the
video with when baby just uh
you seen the video when baby just won
like a million dollars at the casino I
think he was playing Barker up um
I did that like a couple months ago you
made a million dollars yeah I mean like
I probably made like 1.9 million dollars
bro
okay so that sounds amazing
you're gonna show me yeah I already knew
it and for anybody who gambles that
sounds great but that also means
I took like 45 000. okay okay because
I'm just trying to figure out all right
are you are you up or are you even
because yeah yeah you might have you
might have gotten wrong one there right
it's like it's like you might have won
that but yeah but over the totality of
your gambling career I don't keep going
like that now would you say you're
closer to even are you up or are you
down because 1.9 million that's a big
hit yeah I'm I'm alive I'm closer to
even though bro cause I gamble you gotta
think you you go spend money you're
closer to even yeah you will spend money
and then you go back and then you lose
money yeah do they know you like when
you go you get like the VIP treatment
they'd be like here you have a room sir
yeah yeah I get like a I got I got like
yeah I get penthouses and all that not
and not because you're a famous artist
no because because you're like spending
money with them yeah they want you to
stay yeah they want them to stay they
give you all the free food you're asking
for all damn that's serious I was gonna
say can I see my camera roll my camera
roll crazy no no no no we don't want to
see he's not getting whatever
bro bro he said what's the angle here
because there's a lot of all right I had
to look back at the camera all right
what is the video nobody wants to scroll
too far don't accidentally show me
something I don't want to see you no man
I don't need to see how much of a lover
boy you are no no no you don't need to
see this show me the [ __ ] gambling
the gambling video or picture 1.9
million is crazy I play craps I play
roulette you play craps and roulette I
can't I don't know what background is
I'm going to Vegas tomorrow though so
maybe I'll try it out I'll go hang out
you're going to Vegas forever tomorrow
yeah I'm gonna go hang out with some
Asians and be like yo my friend told me
I should be playing this game with y'all
that's the game bro I'm gonna bring some
Marlboros I'm gonna get them from Neil
from your label is there we're gonna go
smoke and gamble with some Asians try to
win 1.9 million you went you won that
off of 45k yes sir
[ __ ] 45
000. where is this I all right hold on
we're getting close and what what what
state is this in Vegas or is this in
Vegas oh yeah you lit like once you just
move to Vegas okay here we go here we go
here we go nope a lot
why don't I move to Vegas Vegas is crazy
bro no state tax yeah no state tax so
that's the that's the that's the crazy
part bro let me and then we gonna and
then we gonna but the crazy part is
right
I didn't I didn't know that okay
um I didn't know that with table games
it's no text yeah right
so I won the money
they asked me did I want
a jet to go home
I don't fly with private jets I I still
get on Commercial fronts right ask me
did I want a jet the jet like forty
thousand dollars I just [ __ ] won 1.9
million yeah [ __ ] it's nothing yeah
yo bro I said no because I was scared
I'm like yo nah it's some freaky [ __ ]
going on I just want all this money from
them like they're trying to [ __ ]
they're gonna disappear you or something
they're trying to get me like what's the
name of that [ __ ] uh TV show where
the [ __ ] plane flew back in time lost
bro whatever the [ __ ] the name oh oh no
no uh
manifest manifest yeah bro are they
trying to [ __ ] manifest me yeah maybe
so I'm like nah like I'm not I'm not I'm
cool I'm cool on the flight which casino
is this this is uh this uh so I won at
the cosmo great casino by the way tons
of hookers past 12. right I wanted the
cosmo and then you know [ __ ] the cosmo
up I'm actually being from there that's
another as you would be yeah because you
won you took two million dollars from
that [ __ ] bed me so boom right
whatever the case may be I [ __ ] put
the money in my bank account and fly
home
bro I gotta [ __ ] pay taxes on that
[ __ ] now because I put it in my bank
account you should have just took the
cash and been like I'm gonna live off of
this cash for the rest of the year I'll
put it in my bank account now I gotta
pay taxes on it Bros and that's like
half crazy story how much how much is
that about that's like half right uh
close to it yeah
look at that that's one of the videos
oh my God they gave you all that cash
and you put it in the bank
yeah
I'm gonna gamble with you
let's do it and that's not even all of
it bro that's like 800 that's like 800
of it right there